- Dans le fond, ici, on fait
la distribution de matériel
de consommation.
- Avec ses unités mobiles,
l'Anonyme a vu les effets
de la pandémie
sur les sans-abri.
JULIEN MONTREUIL, dir. adjoint
de l'organisme l'Anonyme
- Les endroits qui étaient
des "hot spots", bien, ils sont
pas mal moins "hot" qu'avant.
On voit moins de monde, ils
sont... Donc, à ce moment-là,
on se dit : ils sont où,
ces personnes-là?
- Une itinérance plus cachée
renforcée par la crise
du logement.
- Moi, j'aurais besoin juste
d'un petit logement, un petit
studio, là, ça ferait bien
mon affaire.
- Québec annonce qu'il injecte
280 millions sur 5 ans dans
le cadre du plan d'action
interministériel en itinérance
2021-2026.
LIONEL CARMANT, ministre délégué
Santé et Services sociaux, Qc
- Mon but, c'est d'amener
un changement de culture
dans la prise en charge
de l'itinérance.
- L'argent servira, entre
autres, à augmenter le nombre
d'hébergements, particulièrement
ceux pour les femmes;
à doubler l'aide au programme
de soutien au logement;
à créer des refuges qui
permettent la consommation
d'alcool. Mais d'abord, l'argent
servira à la prévention.
- On va prévenir l'itinérance
après les centres jeunesse.
On va prévenir l'itinérance
après les ressources
en dépendance. On va prévenir
l'itinérance après
l'incarcération. On va prévenir
l'itinérance dans
toutes ses modalités.
- Un plan salué par
les candidats à la mairie
de Montréal et par
les organismes du milieu.
JAMES HUGUES, président et chef
de direction Mission Old Brewery
- Ça démontre un sérieux
face à un problème qui
est en pleine croissance.
ANNIE SAVAGE, dir. gén. Réseau
aide aux personnes itinérantes
- Il y a une reconnaissance
des parcours en itinérance,
une reconnaissance du rythme
des personnes. Donc, on est
vraiment dans une perspective
d'approche globale
et communautaire.
CÉCILE ARBAUD, directrice
générale Dans la rue
- C'est très encourageant.
Il ne faut juste pas que
ça reste limité aux seuls
jeunes qui sortent
des centres jeunesse.
- Et la crise du logement qui
sévit n'est pas lié uniquement
aux loyers trop élevés.
MATHIEU FRAPPIER, Réseau org. et
interv. en itinérance de Laval
- Dans notre contexte, à Laval,
c'est beaucoup ça :
non seulement les loyers
sont chers, mais il y en a
vraiment très, très, très peu.
- Le gouvernement prévoit
présenter son plan de mesures
hivernales dans les prochaines
semaines, des mesures qui
deviendront permanentes.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréal.